SLANDER, BREATH BURNED ME.
THAT IS ALL HAPPENING IN
TONIGHT'S OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
BREAKING TONIGHT MOMENTS AGO,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTED
ROBERT MUELLER HAS INFORMED
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LAWYERS THAT
THE PRESIDENT, WELL, STILL THE
WITCH HUNT CONTINUES HOWEVER, HE
IS NOT CURRENTLY A CRIMINAL
TARGET.
IT'S IMPORTANT NEWS.
"THE POST" IS REPORTING THAT
MUELLER IS PREPARING TO REPORT
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S ACTIONS
WHILE IN OFFICE AND POTENTIAL
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
WE WILL ANALYZE THIS NEW
DEVELOPMENT IN A MINUTE BUT
FIRST, WE ALSO HAVE THE
PRESIDENT REFUSING TO BACK AWAY
FROM HIS PROMISE TO SECURE
AMERICA'S BORDERS.
HERE'S THE CURRENT SITUATION.
CONGRESS HAS REPEATEDLY FAILED
TO PASS TOUGH IMMIGRATION LAWS
AND PEOPLE ARE FLOODING INTO OUR
COUNTRY.
DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE BEEN
OBSTRUCTING EVERY SINGLE STEP OF
THE WAY.
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
SOLVING PROBLEMS.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN INTERESTED IN
HELPING DACA RECIPIENTS BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO MAKE THIS A BIG
CAMPAIGN ISSUE IN 2018 THIS YEAR
CAMPAIGN ISSUE IN 2018 THIS YEA
YEAR.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THAT
CARAVAN OF MORE THAN 1,000
ASYLUM-SEEKERS AND IMMIGRANTS
HEADING FOR THE UNITED STATES
HAS NOW REPORTEDLY STALLED OUT
IN MEXICO.
THIS COMES AFTER THE PRESIDENT
SAID HE PRESSURED MEXICO TO DO
SO.
WATCH THIS.
>> I HAVE JUST HEARD THAT THE
CARAVAN COMING UP FROM HONDURAS
HAS BROKEN UP IN MEXICO DID
THAT.
THEY DID IT BECAUSE FRANKLY I
SAID, YOU REALLY HAVE TO DO IT.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP ON NAFTA AND WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO INCLUDE
SECURITY IN NAFTA.
SO MEXICO, VERY STRONG LAWS, AND
THAT IS THE WAY IT IS.
SO IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S BEEN
BROKEN UP.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT ALSO
TONIGHT SIGNALING THAT HE IS
DONE PLAYING GAMES WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR BORDER SECURITY.
HE IS NOW SAYING HE WILL USE THE
U.S. MILITARY TO HELP SECURE THE
BORDER.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO I TOLD MEXICO, AND I
RESPECT WHAT THEY DID, I SAID,
LOOK, YOUR LAWS ARE VERY
POWERFUL, YOUR LAWS ARE VERY
STRONG.
WE HAVE VERY BAD LAWS FOR OUR
BORDER.
WE ARE GOING TO BE DOING SOME
THINGS, I'VE BEEN SPEAKING WITH
THINGS MILITARILY, UNTIL WE CAN
HAVE A WALL AND PROPER SECURITY,
WE WILL BE GUARDING OUR BORDER
WITH THE MILITARY.
THAT IS A BIG STEP.
WE REALLY HAVEN'T DONE THAT
BEFORE, CERTAINLY NOT VERY MUCH
BEFORE.
>> Sean: THINK ABOUT THIS.
ALL THE DRUG TRAFFICKING, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, AND OF COURSE, THE
POSSIBILITY THAT TERRORISTS,
TOO, CAN CROSS THAT BORDER.
THIS IS A MAJOR NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE AND THERE IS A
REASON WHY MEXICO ALL OF A
SUDDEN NOW APPEARS AT THE LAST
MINUTE WILLING TO COOPERATE WITH
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION TO STOP
THE CARIBBEAN.
IS APPLYING A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF PRESSURE, JUST LIKE HE DID
WITH LITTLE ROCKET MAN,
KIM JONG UN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TELLING
MEXICO, IF THEY DON'T ACT, NAFTA
NEGOTIATIONS WILL BE IN
JEOPARDY.
HE ALSO THREATENED TO PULL
FOREIGN AID FROM HONDURAS, WHERE
MANY OF THESE MIGRANTS ARE
COMING FROM.
IT'S ABOUT TIME AN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT STOOD UP FOR OUR
COUNTRY'S SOVEREIGNTY.
BECAUSE THE MEDIA AND THE LEFT
OF STOOD DISTORT CONSERVATIVE
POSITIONS ON THIS, LET ME BE
CLEAR.
THERE IS NOTHING WRONG WITH
PEOPLE COMING TO THE NOTED
STATES OF AMERICA, WE ARE JUST
ASKING IT BE DONE LEGALLY.
WE ARE A CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC, WE HAVE LAWS, THOSE
LAWS NEED TO BE OBEYED.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A COUNTRY WHEN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, NONCITIZENS,
CAN ENTER AS THEY PLEASE.
GUESS BUT, THAT IS WITH THE
PRESIDENT IS NOW TRYING TO DO.
BY THE WAY, ENOUGH IS ENOUGH
WHEN IT COMES TO MEXICO.
PEOPLE LIKE THEIR FORMER
PRESIDENT, HE'S LECTURING US
ABOUT HOW WE DEAL WITH A ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
YET UNDER VICENTE FOX, MEXICO
SHARPLY INCREASED THEIR MILITARY
PRESENCE AT THEIR OWN SOUTHERN
BORDER AND THEY SPENT MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS UPGRADING SECURITY
CHECKPOINTS.
AS A RESULT, FROM 2002-2006,
DETENTIONS, DEPORTATIONS
INCREASED BY 74% AND MEXICO.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
BEYOND HYPOCRITICAL, FOR MEXICO
TO CONSTANTLY BE LECTURING THE
UNITED STATES REGARDING
IMMIGRATION LAWS WHEN THEY ARE
FAR TOUGHER THAN WE'VE EVER BEEN
FAR TOUGHER THAN WE'VE EVER BEE
BEEN.
FOR SENDING MILITARY PERSONNEL
TO SECURE THE BORDERS, WELCOME
THE LIBERALS OF THE MEDIA ARE SO
OUTRAGED THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WOULD DARE TO DO THAT.
HERE'S THE THING, THEY ARE
COMPLETELY SILENT OF COURSE ON
PRESIDENT OBAMA DID THAT EXACT
SAME THING BACK IN 2010.
BACK THEN, OBAMA SENT 1200
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS TO THE
BORDER TO HELP BORDER PATROL
AGENTS.
REMEMBER IN 2014, FORMER TEXAS
GOVERNOR RICK PERRY CALLED UP
THE NATIONAL GUARD TO PROTECT
THE BORDER BECAUSE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WASN'T DOING
ENOUGH.
IT'S NOT LIKE THIS IS
UNPRECEDENTED.
HERE'S ANOTHER POINT.
THE LIBERAL MEDIA WILL NEVER
TELL YOU.
THEY WERE SO QUICK TO CRITICIZE
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR SAYING THAT
HE WANTS TO USE PART OF THE
MILITARY'S BUDGET TO BUILD A
BORDER WALL.
IT'S A NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE.
ACCORDING TO A 2009
CONGRESSIONAL RESEARCH SERVICE
REPORT, THE MILITARY HAS ALREADY
BEEN USED TO HELP CONSTRUCT THE
BORDER WALL BY PAST PRESIDENTS.
INCLUDING GEORGE W. BUSH AND
EVEN BARACK OBAMA.
THOSE ARE FACTS THE MEDIA WILL
NEVER TELL YOU ANY OF THIS,
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T FIT THEIR
ANTI-TRUMP AGENDA.
ACCORDING TO A NEW SURVEY, 89%
OF BORDER PATROL AGENTS SAY A
WALL SYSTEM IN STRATEGIC
VOCATIONS IS NECESSARY TO SECURE
THE BORDER.
THAT IS COMING DIRECTLY FROM THE
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND THERE EVERY
DAY RISKING THEIR LIVES.
WHY NOT GIVE THEM WHAT THEY ARE
ASKING FOR IT?
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CALLING
FOR IS SECURITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IT IS THAT SIMPLE.
FOR THE RECORD, THIS POSITION IS
SIMILAR TO THE ONE THAT BARACK
HUSSEIN OBAMA ONCE HELD.
YOU MAY REMEMBER HIM SAYING THIS
YOU MAY REMEMBER HIM SAYING THI
THIS.
>> THOSE WHO ENTER OUR COUNTRY
LEGALLY AND THOSE WHO EMPLOY
THEM DISRESPECT THE RULE OF LAW.
AND BECAUSE WE LIVE IN AN AGE
WHERE TERRORISTS ARE CHALLENGING
OUR BORDERS, WE CANNOT ALLOW
PEOPLE TO POUR INTO THE U.S.
UNDETECTED, UNDOCUMENTED, AND
UNCHECKED.
>> Sean: WOW, HE SOUNDS LIKE
DONALD TRUMP.
OBAMA ONLY CHANGED HIS STANCE
WHEN IT BECAME POLITICALLY
EXPEDIENT.
AS FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP,
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WILL PUT
QUOTAS IN PLACE AND START
EVALUATING IMMIGRATION JUDGES ON
THE NUMBER OF CASES THAT THEY
HEAR IN ORDER TO SPEED UP AND
EXPEDITE POTENTIAL DEPORTATIONS
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
REMEMBER, SOMEONE GETS CAUGHT
ENTERING AMERICA ILLEGALLY, THEY
ARE ACTUALLY ALLOWED TO STAY
HERE UNTIL THEY GET TO THEIR
COURT DATE, AND ABOUT 98% OF
THEM NEVER SHOW UP.
SO IT IS THE HEIGHT OF IGNORANCE
AND STUPIDITY AND THAT IS WHY
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTS TO CHANGE
IT.
OTHER COUNTRIES, FOR EXAMPLE,
LET'S LOOK AT AUSTRALIA.
THEY DON'T ROLL OUT THE
RED CARPET FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS LIKE WE DO.
NOW WHEN AUSTRALIA CATCHES
ASYLUM-SEEKERS TRYING TO ENTER
THEIR COUNTRY, THEY ARE VERY
COMPASSIONATE.
THEY GIVE THEM FOOD, THEY GIVE
THEM WATER, THEY GAVE THE
MEDICAL ATTENTION IF THEY NEEDED
TO.
THEN THEY SEND THE MIGRANTS BACK
FROM WHERE THEY CAME.
THAT IS BEYOND PAST TIME THAT
AMERICA USED THE SAME COMMON
SENSE TO SECURE OUR BORDERS.
ALSO BRAND-NEW TONIGHT, ANOTHER
MAJOR REPORT, SARA CARTER WILL
JOIN US.
BOMBSHELL SACRED TEXTS SHOW FBI,
DOJ MAY HAVE RUSHED ANTI-TRUMP
FISA WARRANT'S.
ACCORDING TO SARA CARTER,
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATORS HAVE
DISCOVERED NEW TEXT MESSAGES
BETWEEN ANTI-TRUMP FBI AGENTS,
LOVEBIRDS, PETER STRZOK AND LISA
PAGE THAT SHOW POSSIBLE
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE FBI AND
THE DOJ TO GET A FISA WARRANT TO
SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE, CARTER PAGE.
IN ONE OF THE TEXT MESSAGES,
SARA, STRZOK IS WHINING AND
COMPLAINING TO PAIGE THAT A
WARRANT IN THE INVESTIGATION IS
BEING HELD UP.
ONE OF THE CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATORS IS TELLING SARA
TONIGHT, "EVERYTHING HERE FROM
THE TEXTS, COMPLAINING ABOUT
FISA DELAYS TO THE EXCHANGES
INDICATING COORDINATION COME
MUCH TO THE RIGHT HAS COME A
VISITORS LOG, IT SEEMS TO MATCH
TO A DISTURBING DEGREE.
AT BEST, IT'S A STRANGE
COINCIDENCE WORTH INVESTIGATING.
IT'S MUCH LIKELY MORE."
YOU HAVE THE FBI USING AN
UNVERIFIED COOKED AND BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR A DOSSIER AS PART OF
FIS APPLICATION, THEN THEY
RUSH TO GET A FISA WARRANT
APPROVED, NEW EVIDENCE POINTS TO
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE, THE FBI, DOJ,
AND THE CIA.
SARA WILL EXPLAIN ALL OF US IN A
FEW MINUTES.
ALSO TONIGHT'S, FIRST
CONVICTION.
GOT TO GIVE HIM A LOT OF CREDIT
AND HIS WITCH HUNT.
A DUTCH LAWYER WAS JUST
SENTENCED TO 30 DAYS IN JAIL.
30 WHOLE DAYS.
AND HE'S BEING ORDERED TO PAY
$20,000 FINE FOR LYING TO THE
FBI.
THAT'S IT?
AND IT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THE MEDIA PLAYED THIS UP.
THEY THOUGHT THIS GUY WAS
GETTING 20 YEARS.
IN REALITY, IT LOOKS LIKE A
GIANT WASTE OF YOUR MONEY.
WHILE THE MEDIA WAS HYPER
FOCUSED ON THIS APPARENT DUTCH
LAWYER AND THIS TRAVESTY, THEY
MISSED A MASSIVE STORY THAT
PROVES ROBERT MUELLER IS
CARRYING OUT A WITCH HUNT THAT
IS BEING AIDED AND ABETTED BY
HIS BODY, THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN.
ACCORDING TO AN AUGUST MEMO, HE
ACTUALLY AUTHORIZED HIM TO GO
AFTER PAUL MANAFORT'S WORK WITH
THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT WHICH
HAPPENED WAY, WAY BEFORE
PAUL MANAFORT ANYTHING HAD
ANYTHING TO DO WITH DONALD TRUMP
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, NONE OF THE
CHARGES PAUL MANAFORT IS FACING
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH ANY OF
THAT.
OF COURSE, THAT IT'S ONLY HALF
THE STORY.
WASHINGTON TIMES REPORTING THAT
MUELLER INVESTIGATED
PAUL MANAFORT ON AN ALLEGATION
FROM THE NEVER CORROBORATED, NOW
KNOWN TO BE LIES THAT CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER,
THAT CAME FROM A NONNAMED
RUSSIAN SOURCE AND SOURCES.
PRETTY SHOCKING BUT IT SHOULDN'T
COME AS A SURPRISE.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER AS
CORRUPT AS THEY COME.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
TRUTH.
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT FACTS.
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT EVIDENCE.
DOESN'T CARE THAT HE'S BIASED.
LOOK AT THE TVs ASSEMBLED, A
TEAM OF DEMOCRATIC DONORS THAT
DONATED TO HILLARY, OBAMA,
THE DNC.
WE CAN'T IGNORE THAT ROD
ROSENSTEIN, HE'S A GUY THAT
APPOINTED MUELLER, ROSENSTEIN IS
GIVING MUELLER FREE REIGN TO DO
WHATEVER HE WANTS.
WHATEVER HAPPENED, BY THE WAY,
TO THIS SO-CALLED COLLUSION?
TURN OUT TO BE A WITCH HUNT.
ROD ROSENSTEIN, YOU SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF HIMSELF AND FRANKLY,
HE'S THE SAME GUY THAT SIGNED
THE FISA EXTENSION AGAINST TRUMP
ASSOCIATE CARTER PAGE AND THEN
APPOINTED TO MUELLER.
DOES ANYONE SEE THAT AS A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST?
LIKE WE HAVE BEEN SAYING,
ROSENSTEIN NEEDS TO GO.
ALSO TONIGHT COME A BRAND-NEW
POLL, 67% OF YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THINK A SECOND SPECIAL
COUNSEL SHOULD IN FACT WE NAMED
TO INVESTIGATE ALL THE
DISTURBING FISA ABUSES THAT
WE'VE BEEN REPORTING ON AND THE
MEDIA'S BEEN IGNORING IT.
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
UNDERSTAND THE SEVERITY OF IT
BECAUSE OF IT'S A MASSIVE ABUSEO
BECAUSE OF IT'S A MASSIVE ABUSEF
POWER AND THE DOJ AND THE FBI,
THEY CANNOT INVESTIGATE
THEMSELVES, BECAUSE THAT IS A
MASSIVE CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
CALLED ABUSE OF POWER.
NOW WHILE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
JEFF SESSIONS AND SAID HE WON'T
BE NAMING US BUT WOW SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL, HE HAS APPOINTD
SPECIAL COUNSEL, HE HAS APPOINTU
SPECIAL COUNSEL, HE HAS APPOINTA
SPECIAL COUNSEL, HE HAS APPOINTH
PROSECUTOR JOHN UBER.
SINCE NOVEMBER, WE DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT IT -- GOOD FOR
JEFF SESSIONS -- TO SERVE IN A
SIMILAR CAPACITY.
WHILE IT'S NOT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL, IT'S A MASSIVE
DEVELOPMENT.
AS A FEDERAL PROSECUTOR, HE WILL
BE ABLE TO CONVENE A GRAND JURY,
GATHER EVIDENCE, ISSUE
SUBPOENAS, HAVE WITNESSES
TESTIFY, AND THAT MEANS HE'LL BE
ABLE TO PROPERLY INVESTIGATE
THESE FISA ABUSES.
THE FBI PUTTING THE FIX IT ON
THE CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION.
KICKBACKS TO THE CODE THE
FOUNDATION, THE CORRUPT
URANIUM ONE DEAL AND LYING TO A
FISA JUDGE AND THE PHONY DOSSIER
THAT SHE PAID FOR.
MAJOR DEVELOPMENT AND IT'S JUST
GETTING STARTED.
ANOTHER QUICK POINT TONIGHT.
JOE McCABE, SHE IS THE WIFE OF
THE FIRED FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
McCABE, SHE HAS AN OP-ED IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST," WHERE SHE
IS CLAIMING TO BE SETTING THE
RECORD STRAIGHT.
PREDICTABLY, JILL McCABE
EXCUSES THE FACT THAT HER
HUSBAND WAS FIRED FOR LYING
UNDER OATH MULTIPLE TIMES ABOUT
A NUMBER OF ISSUES.
INSTEAD, SHE'S BLAMING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE DOG BITES, THE BEE STINGS,
IF YOU'RE FEELING SAD, AND IF
YOU HAVE A HEADACHE, AND
HANGOVER, IT'S DONALD TRUMP'S
FAULTS.
JILL McCABE SEEMS TO BE
DOWNPLAYING THE FACT SHE GOT
OVER $700,000 OF CAMPAIGN MONEY
FROM KEY CLINTON ALLIED BFF
TERRY McAULIFFE AND THE
VIRGINIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHEN
SHE HAD A FAILED STATE SENATE
RUN.
STATE SENATE CANDIDATES IN
VIRGINIA, THEY NEVER GET THAT
KIND OF MONEY.
SO THE McCABES CAN WHINE ALL
THEY WANT IN PUBLIC ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED BUT FACTS ARE FACTS.
YOU CAN'T CHANGE THAT.
ALL RIGHT, FINALLY TONIGHT, I
HAVE A SPECIAL MESSAGE FOR THE
ABUSIVELY BIASED MEDIA THAT ONCE
AGAIN I STRIKE TO SMEAR ME.
YESTERDAY ON MY RADIO SHOW, I
WAS MAKING A POINT ABOUT
ROBERT MUELLER DIVIDING THIS
COUNTRY AT A LEVEL WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN IN FOREVER.
WHAT HE HAS BEEN DOING, I MADE
REFERENCE, IT'S LIKE A CIVIL WAR
IN THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE OF HIS
ABUSIVELY BIASED THEME, CORRUPT
DEMOCRATS, WE ARE SICK AND TIRED
DEMOCRATS, WE ARE SICK AND TIREO
DEMOCRATS, WE ARE SICK AND TIREF
DEMOCRATS, WE ARE SICK AND TIREI
DEMOCRATS, WE ARE SICK AND TIRE.
IT'S DIVIDING THOSE THAT HATE
TRUMP.
THOSE THAT LIKE DONALD TRUMP.
LOOK AT THE PERSON LIKE ANDREW
WEISSMANN HE APPOINTED.
WHAT THE MEDIA DIDN'T REPORT TO
YOU, I WAS TALKING ABOUT A
REALLY DEEP DIVIDE THAT THE
ERROR AGAIN TO MUELLER'S
CREATING AND THAT AMERICANS ARE
MORE DIVIDED THAN EVER AND I
WAS ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT
FAMILY MEMBERS, A CIVIL WAR, AND
THEY WILL SIT AT DINNER AND THEY
WILL HAVE A FOOD FIGHTS AND THEY
WILL THROW MASHED POTATOES AND
BROCCOLI AT EACH OTHER AT THE
DINNER TABLE.
I WASN'T TALKING ABOUT A REAL
CIVIL WAR AND I WAS VERY CLEAR.
NOW THIS IS SAID THAT MEDIA INTO
A FRENZY.
BUT THEY QUICKLY IGNORED
EVERYTHING I SAID.
THEY RAISED TO TAKE ME OUT OF
CONTEXT, LIKE THEY ALWAYS DO.
CLAIMING THAT HANNITY WANTS A
CIVIL WAR IN AMERICA.
NO, I'M SAYING WE ARE MORE
DIVIDED THAN EVER.
AS YOU KNOW FROM WATCHING THE
SHOW, THAT IS WITH THE MEDIA
DOES ALL THE TIME BUT I'M NOT
GOING TO SIT BACK AND TAKE THEIR
CRAP.
WE WILL CALL AT THE CORRUPT
MEDIA IN THE COUNTRY.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE MEDIA LOST IT
AT ME SAYING THE WORD
"CIVIL WAR."
WE WENT TO THE ARCHIVES.
THEY HAVE SAID IT MANY MORE
TIMES THAN I HAVE.
WE HAVE GOT THE PROOF.
>> HE IS CLEARLY TRYING TO
IGNITE A CIVIL WAR IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF A COLD
CIVIL WAR IN THIS COUNTRY.
A POLITICAL AND CULTURAL
CIVIL WAR.
>> TONIGHT WE ARE WATCHING A
CIVIL WAR BETWEEN MOSTLY
SOUTHERN SENATORS LOYAL TO THE
MAN FROM ALABAMA.
>> THE ONLY CIVIL WAR I SEE IS
ON TWITTER AND THAT DOESN'T EVEN
REALLY MATTER.
AS BIG A GOVERNOR, YOU'VE CALLED
THIS AN ECONOMIC CIVIL WAR, AND
ALL THAT IS WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> IN A WAY I UNDERSTAND IT
BECAUSE WE ARE FIGHTING THE LAST
BATTLE OF CIVIL WAR.
>> Sean: OH, NOBODY CARED
ABOUT THEM SAYING IT.
SO THE MEDIA CAN'T STAND THE
FACT -- THIS IS THE TRUTH --
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT ON THIS
PROGRAM, WE ARE PROVING THEM TO
BE COMPLETE, TOTAL LIARS AND
FRAUDS, ABUSIVELY BIASED, ON
EVERYTHING INVOLVING
DONALD TRUMP.
AND SADLY, THEY HAVE MISSED THE
BIGGEST STORY OF THEIR LIFETIMES
WHILE THEY HAVE BEEN OBSESSING
OVER A TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION
CONSPIRACY THEORY WHERE THERE IS
NO EVIDENCE.
AND NOW THAT THE LIBERAL MEDIA
HAS BEEN EXPOSED, THEY ARE
LASHING OUT AT PEOPLE LIKE ME.
WE'VE BEEN RIGHT.
IT'S NO WONDER THERE IS A   A NW
POLL FROM MONMOUTH UNIVERSITY
SHOWING THAT 77% TO VIEW THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BELIEVE THE
TRADITIONAL MEDIA IN THIS
COUNTRY REPORTS FAKE NEWS
BECAUSE THEY DO.
AT THIS POINT, IT'S PRETTY MUCH